[Applause]
ubra starting to come on he had a just a
a horrible start to the season as harden
swishes a three
now they have a hardened screen
and he just walks into a mid-range
jumper but shoot the ball well early
just 4 13 here in the first half
perhaps happy i liked how pasco switched
up and into the ball durant
nails a three-pointer young rookies turn
into those
wiry veterans that play that role you
look at draymond green he
impacted guys like jared jack who's done
an
outstanding job yesterday in the g
league see the warriors little
three-quarter court falling back into a
little 2-3 zone trying to disrupt the
nets
offensively harden left open
that's a three james harden
durant searching for an opening pass
inside finds its way to harrison he
banks it in
talking about threading the needle steve
kerr his team is coming out in this
third quarter
not getting it done defensively the
thread's a needle pass by kevin durant
so two very important front court
players for them
still remain out kyrie irving steps back
and hits a three-pointer
look at the degree of difficulty the
ability to
make plays change direction take hit
like
four or five highlight passes like right
there oh that's just gorgeous that's a
difficult one-handed shot from jeff
green
and this one looking up
that is thrown right on target well
that's
that's saying a lot he he's just i mean
look at that right on cue rachel just
spectacular guys i mean like the handle
and the footwork
and the ability to finish todd
strickland would eat two hot dogs before
the game
and then go drop 30.
kevin durant with an easy slam james
harden magnificent
16 points 14 assists
hardin again james harden from downtown
his fifth three-pointer
that's kyrie irving i mean he is just oh
and the foul this is wizardry right now
strength and then the just burst of
speed
using the rim